things are heating up between Scott
Disick and Sophia Richie but what does
Kourtney Kardashian think about it I'm
over it the reality star and the 19 year
old model have been spotted getting cozy
all over the globe use your into packing
on the PDA in Mexico Miami and Italy
there's never a dull moment now a source
tells et that the two are going strong
quote they're still together and they
are having fun the source adds that
Lionel Richie's daughter has known
Disick for a long time quote they'd hung
out socially before but just reconnected
romantically in the past few months this
is a serious the two first sparked
romance rumors at the 2017 can Film
Festival in May at the time Ritchie who
previously dated Justin Bieber adamantly
denied anything romantic was going on
tweeting that the two were quote just
homies so how does Disick's ex feel
about their budding romance there's just
too much going on a source tells ET she
isn't fazed quote at this point Courtney
isn't interested in Scott as a romantic
partner she does not care who he dates
or who he spends his time with and the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians star has
been spending time with her beau 24 year
old model Eunice Benjamin I've never
known Courtney to be this giddy ever in
my life but the source was quick to
shoot down the rumors that she's
pregnant with baby number four quote of
course that would make a juicy headline
but sorry it's not true
[Music]